[Music]
47 seconds of logos philosophical
reading 50 years ago in duration it was
only through the sacrifice of our
greatest commander that we avoided total
annihilation it was forever known as the
Randy Quaid maneuver also his one ship
crashed into that ship and the battle
was over if it's not that it's water or
germs we really underestimate aliens
that have conquered space travel don't
we I am one of those recruits awesome
because if you're not we're talking
about a really short movie I'm not
telling you he's the one having either
one you miscalculated you trajectory
relative to the incoming asteroid don't
lecture me Wiggin we were told just a
minute ago that this program recruits
the smartest children so what did they
see in this typical cliche movie bully
if the plastic show up in this thing I'm
out
that's bone hurt a bit what does the end
game Enders game telling him it won't
hurt when it clearly will I know they
want to see how he'll respond to getting
kicked out of the program lying to him
about the pain of this procedure come on
you find out in a minute that the two
bosses are watching this all go down and
not stopping it even though someone
definitely could have been killed
scanner monitor now that's right no I
watch you now but presumably you bully
dicks all still have monitors which
means someone's watching you right I
thought you had to be smart to get into
the school and we'll get in trouble for
this but he shouldn't he should get a
medal in the mom and dad spend all that
money on a third now is up the program
too I've read the book so I know that
third has derogatory connotations
probably to the point the polite society
calls it the T word but I'll be damned
if this movie ever explains it I mean if
you really wanted to stop what was
happening couldn't you've just broken
one or more of those panes of glass in
the door also this movie's been going
for seven minutes and it's made up of
80% ass-beating so far
please state your name
you mean they couldn't call first final
step in our evaluation is always to see
what happens when the monitors removed
okay she should finish this by saying
with admiration and you son nearly kick
the guy to death that's not what he did
it's why he did it
it was tactical a strategy to stop
future attacks so you must have been
really certain that the bullies would
confront him afterward in order to get
that information huh
you've got what a few hours to make that
determination before he goes home and
you can't monitor him anymore
also it's almost like Harrison Ford took
his branch rickey character from 42 and
just continued it here he wants the guy
who's got the guts not to fight back the
others eyes see the last person on board
this ship it's not like they recruited
him while all these other careers we're
waiting rank you late out of my control
this is the most egregious example thus
far of the you're late problem in
Hollywood screenplays there is no
authority relationship between these two
and literally no consequence for the
tardiness just mindless chatter to fill
time and what kind of name is that
what's your name names bean your fucking
name is bean and you had the audacity to
mock another person's name you beam you
can dick God you suck the society has
solar panel launch rockets and genetic
prediction abilities so other than zero
gravity why would the battle school need
to actually take place in space why
can't you train these fools on earth and
even simulate zero gravity with your
future technology antigravity vomit anti
grab a vomit there's only one kid on
this launch with any brains at all so
far and that's Indra Wiggin this is what
the military refers to as painting the
target as isolation can never be broken
they must never believe anyone will help
them what why does your neo commander
need to be isolated
you are literally guessing but passing
it off as fact considering you've never
done what you're trying to do oh look
it's a smart ass while I understand that
they're reacting this way because
Harrison Ford singled amount don't all
these kids know the pain of being
bullied because of their intellect what
they challenge much like he was don't
they know everything is a test at this
point I don't have to ask to be by the
door speak your name Andrew Wiggins so
they left him this last bunk by the door
but somehow saying his name into the
voiceprint thing at this bunk unlocks it
and all the inside the lockers gonna fit
him perfectly but if you're looking for
a shoulder to cry on use a pillow do I
look like a joke it's not we're all
these assholes already in some sort of
military academy before they made it
here this isn't boot camp they know
better if
you're found in an area not designated
to your gender I will personally do to
you North Carolina welcome to battle
school a great responsibility rests upon
each of you and it comes with great
power oh wait get up tonight kids in
battle school are subjected to the
beginning of Enders game also is this
video of the guy who blew himself up
edited like a Hollywood movie did they
find feeds from everywhere like the
people who made Chronicle did let's move
it along
geez you've got ten nights ten minutes
is barely enough time to even wake up I
know this is some kind of military or
whatever but the entire movie they keep
waking people up ten minutes before
important about ninety percent of a face
ship if you're going to go to ninety
percent why stop there do you need to
let in air if you're gonna leave part of
it open presumably for air why not just
shield the eyes and call it a day
like it like they're a bug to be crushed
under our feet I just realized this
movie is a lot like Starship Troopers or
that Starship Troopers is a lot like
this book or something I'm not sure
there's ass in here but I'll have one
just to be sure this is amazing I can't
move at all now sounds dope you're
flapping around like a bunch of drunken
ducks sergeant explain the game yeah
let's insulting recruits before you ever
give them any idea what the fuck was
going on you get one point for hit to a
limb sick for at all some of it and this
game will somehow prepare you to pilot
massive space warships against other
massive warships just go with it man yes
I know they're looking at leadership and
tactics but still tons of easier ways to
observe that kind of if either side gets
one cadet through the enemy's gate
unharmed that army will win regardless
of points already scored so it's like
the snitch in Quidditch and it makes
everything else you do essentially
worthless great game dear Valentine so
this is battle school email raishin and
no one ever adequately explains how
mazer rackham
actually defeated the entire fleet ender
would be amazing at cinemasins and it's
kind of crazy that this incomplete story
got this much traction over the years
without a great many people questioning
it wait a minute didn't ender make a
buddy when they were in the antigravity
chamber or a minute ago is this a thing
nerds who shown other nerds sorry now
being blocked all communication is being
temporarily held back this seems like
something they would have been told like
the first day what benefit is there not
to tell them I feel like the scene was
put in so that Harrison Ford could get
his mandatory I'm certainly seen in and
fulfill his contract you will never
salute you push up shadowing shadow we
have only
three passing scores on the deep-space
navigation test now the problem was
simple I'm confused as to how these
other smart kids got into the program if
they couldn't solve this simple problem
if getting through the first leg of the
training is so difficult to get into
battle school how three people pass this
test I mean seriously this is the type
of thing that threatens an entire movies
credibility when dicks like this can get
into an elite school that the movie has
tried so hard to tell us it's impossible
to get into that occasional break in
whose sent fist I love how this
classroom apparently has a class-wide
anonymized chat application running on
all these computers it's working their
plan to make enter into a leader by
berating him punishing him and blocking
his emails to home is working yay
everyone lights under now and the
shining is still cool welcome to games
and recreations Jesus don't they have
headphones at battle school
holy Christ that's horrifying why would
a game developer in a game where your
actions are supposedly to choose one of
two cups even program in a combination
of buttons to allow this was there no
option just to eat the cheese I'm sorry
but you can't play baseball like this
any kind of well struck ball will hit
the ceiling immediately and later we
find out the battle room is open 24/7
why not play this game and the awesome
antigravity chamber since nobody who
runs the ship gives a shit what you do
with the free time also bonza must have
thrown quite the fastball for dink to be
this late on it and hit it straight to
ender who's constantly making dramatic
entrances in this movie quick study I
may be clear I intend to trade you ASAP
trade we this training center
inadvertently creates some kind of
sports league is baffling he's in charge
of a squad even though he's still just a
cadet but he can as a cadet immediately
trade away another cadet the boss is
personally assigned to his squad is this
like a sign-and-trade kind of deal here
is he worried about the salary cap I
think how did enters custom team uniform
make it here before he did he played the
game they decided to promote him and he
walks straight here the uniform
department in this place deserves a
phrase for how on topic they are why
does she even do this like yeah maybe
she's just trying to be nice to the
newbie or she like likes it but since
Bonzo told him to do nothing when they
get into the chamber what good is his
practice does she know Enders gonna be
the special that defeats Lord business
you don't practice with her in fact you
don't practice at all I realize you need
antagonist in a movie but this guy's
bully boner is absurdly big that's the
Dirk Diggler of bully boners wake up me
spend a horse battle with leopard in ten
minutes
ten minutes
I'll grant the fact that salamanders are
predatory animals but they don't exactly
strike fear into me when I hear their
names are you telling me this hyper
violent society that fosters violent
cadets is going to end up on salamander
for a plane mascot the movie will send
this for us but what an extraordinarily
stupid maneuver this is I mean your
solution is to make one big target where
the opposing team doesn't have to be all
that accurate when they shoot I mean
this movie isn't beloved or anything but
it's stuff like this that made it
passable I'd take action scenes this
clever using actual thought and tactics
over 99% of the action scenes I see in
movies today but also one session with a
girl and suddenly he's spinning
spacesuit Jesus with the gunplay also
also the salamander team was like 22 and
out the only reason they're losing right
now is to give Endor a reason to show up
and the only reason the movie gave them
an unbelievably perfect winning record
is to somewhat justify the bully boner
late he was watching the action that
closely from there you can't see
anything from there why not use video
monitors instead of glass windows really
far away could she want him anymore
somehow allowed to happen by all the
adults in this place who spy on everyone
all the time with cameras I'm getting a
little tired of how intentionally
ignorant these adults are with the
bullying that goes on at this Academy
talans hi she doesn't look anything like
Abigail Breslin video game substitutes
for a dream sequence where we're sure to
see Voldemort at some point yep
confirmed I don't his psycho brother end
up in the game he's obviously feeling so
psychologically the only reason the game
is doing this as we later learn is
because the stupid aliens are trying to
use telepathy to communicate with him a
videogame doing this is impossible so
the scene for this is that she casually
chalks it up to psychological pricker
instead of a goddamn miracle a software
is better we've only seen him in the
battle room for official matches once we
have however spent a lot of time on a
stupid video game where a white Walker
makes him drink poison and his brother
is still a dick would you have a habit
of upsetting your commander his
commander actually hasn't habit of being
a douche dragon army sure I've never
heard of a dragon army we discontinued
the name four years ago no dragon army
ever won about I mean did you ever get
those uniforms to anyone who could win a
battle is it because you're
superstitious about dragon army or
because you never put people in those
uniforms who could succeed you know the
Red Sox and Cubs operated just like this
486 and 108 years before they realize
there was no curse just teams that
weren't capable of winning
sir because we already have the uniforms
you Harrison Ford's character whose name
I refuse to learn you those uniforms
cannot possibly fit everyone on whatever
team you're putting together stop trying
to cover up the fact that this facility
has the fastest and most capable
seamstresses alive operating under a
dark shadow secrecy I can't be expected
to do all the thinking in this army can
I be wow isn't that amazing these
misfits they gave endure just happened
to be people he knew from his training
squad but his best friends even awesome
ankle pal well whatever gets Hailee
Steinfeld on my team is a good thing but
like hope that ankle is okay geez look
like that hurt you know if you get under
a sheet on this window he doesn't have
to get woken up by moonlight and
sunlight every 45 minutes let's see how
they hem the formation what kind of
logic is that this is your very first
game is dragon army right they don't
know what to expect at all but surely
they think you know some formations
since that's part of the game right we
should storm him and crush him yeah we
hold our positions he has to come to us
not according to the rules of the game
it's a point based game unless someone
breaches the other side scape otherwise
its points based on leg shots and torso
shots I was paying attention and his
team has shot 12 of your soldiers and
you've shot one of his ander wins on
points with all these kids getting hit
at once and becoming a mobile would they
still be able to hold their positions in
this formation salamander 122 he matches
in a row and after this one match dragon
goes to first place why would they even
in second place did the move to cut all
the times that they played before this I
mean yeah we saw them briefly training a
few minutes ago I guess but were they in
actual competitions
I'm not saying put cameras in the
showers I'm just saying this facility
has live feed video surveillance of its
cadets but somehow let's every single
bullying and beating occur with zero
interference my father trained horses
I've raised yearlings since I was five
years old I know a thoroughbred
because kids and horses are so similar
I've had a lot of fights though and
that's just in the last hour the
training begins first thing tomorrow
morning I'm confused as to what we've
been doing so far sergeant tap I'll show
you to your quarters because he's the
guy you and the viewing audience are
familiar with he's really the only guy
we have to do whatever job he does not
gaudy sir I've already seen this I want
to know what happens after oh come on
ender you're a smart kid you know me as
a Rackham didn't drag you into the video
room to show you the same fucking video
this is the director's cut
after the explosion clear
everything was incredibly still and I
wrote the script Independence Day on the
way down
then they started falling out of the sky
oh yeah there's nowhere near any of the
thousands of ships that should have
crashed into me like a bad Dave Matthews
Band concert what animal is the formics
most often compared dance which have a
cruel so the aliens are hive minded and
that's why all of them died after a
maser killed the Queen seems like a
species this advanced wouldn't have such
a glaring weakness in their defense but
that's how you make killing aliens when
you should have no chance in hell easy
indy500 Petra is trying to fob in what
when did she get trained to do that
it seems like a healthy coincidence to
me play out drones give me for
hyperbolic formations with 90-degree
offsets okay
since when do all these people know all
there is to know about this simulation
the last we saw ender he was conquering
a futuristic version of laser tag and
learning basic military strategies but
now at the drop of a hat he and his
buddies know all the capabilities of
this thing maybe I missed a training
montage how can they be effective if
they don't get any sleep sleep
deprivation is part of your training I'm
not sure that actually enters the
question of one more simulation and I
may have to go to war what happens when
it's no longer a game real war is
different or is it dumb what if they
could talk to us they can't talk a
hailee steinfeld why empathy to think
like a former nothing he's done so far
demonstrates this but whatever suddenly
rapidly approaching the climax movie
neezy sir it's graduation day why would
you wake up your most valued recruits in
this way why not just give them a time
and let them set an alarm what is it
with this movie and waking people up
moments before important events well
that happened I have no idea what it was
but it happened he's abandoning his
entire fleet he's in command there's no
stopping him not considering the reveal
we're about to get it's absolutely
stunning that the people in charge don't
tackle ender during this maneuver this
is gambling the entire fleet something
that they know but ender doesn't know
also is there any indication as to why
they needed kids to do this and even if
they believed kids were better suited
because of their videogame capabilities
or whatever why were there restrictions
on having a third trial seems like a
society that goes all-in on children
running the military would ask parents
to have as many children as possible
here's the phone Ben Kingsley a
screenshot from the Corps distinct ring
you've won all future battles
destroying them see here's where the
movie fails if one is read the book and
knows how the story ends then the entire
movie is a lot and one knows it and it
can't help but keep one from truly
experiencing and enjoying the run it's
the rare example where books twist is so
great that the movie ends up being
pretty much made solely for the people
who never read the book but that being
said it's a great reveal this should
stand as one of the greatest reveals no
matter the medium so we will remove five
cents the comics access the game for me
their thoughts my dreams all mixed
together yeah why
I know ender is special but there's no
reason to think they knew about him and
they never tried it with other
candidates because Viola Davis told us
those images had never shown up in the
game before and if what they were trying
to communicate why did they do it with a
mix of dreamy imagery to the point that
he couldn't discern a real message okay
okay maybe it was a first Rana and they
needed to iron out the kinks and then
the asshole humans deleted the game
before ender could go further
seems like telepathic communication
should work with in a confusing video
game mixing up the message Oh a format
Queen stayed behind on this planet after
all the other formats retreated to
another planet and managed to live long
enough to keep a future Queen and the
survival of the species intact and
luckily discovered a child who could
interpret the video game sequence as
communication deus ex Formica
only through the sacrifice of our
greatest commander that we avoided total
annihilation
you chose one all right thank you smile
squeeze it turn it
what's wrong with this country my money
you taught me that evil defense
contractors had it noble causes did not
politicians are bought and sold like so
much chattel our problems multiplied you
are the weakest link go back I think
you're gonna find yourself one smiling
[Music]
I'm coming up with 32.3 three repeating
of course percentage of survival I'm all
better and we usually do already guys
the Genesis effect matter is reorganized
with life generating results